all right uh jameis winston another guy
who's trying to prove his worth and earn
a second contract bruce arians had some
recent comments that were very
intriguing because you know we used to
hear a lot about quarterbacks using the
virtual reality products that are out
there to get live reps
without getting live reps and when
you've only got limited time to have
practice and contact etc if you can
simulate what it's like to have to make
decisions in real time it's worth it
well you know plenty of teams are still
using virtual reality we're going to be
writing some stuff about this later in
the week it kind of went underground a
little bit i think what happened was we
were hearing about all the teams using
it chris yeah and then it came out the
patriots were using it and the patriots
got pissed right and i think the people
who provide that technology kind of
welcome to a shell yeah yeah but now
it's it they're still it's still a very
popular device remember carson palmer
used it in arizona with bruce arians and
bruce arians is hoping that
jameis winston will do it and it makes
sense especially when you're prone to
make bad decisions
improve your ability to make decisions
by putting yourself in as many
situations as possible chris where you
are seeing things unfold blitzers are
coming out you guys are dropping into
coverage and you have to make good
decisions in real time that's right
there's only so many reps you can get in
the off season you're always trying to
look for an advantage i've put one of
these things on before i've never really
like gone through a full session i would
love to do it at some point um i'm
i think you're totally right mike i
think most teams if not every team in
football has this going on right now i
mean if you're a quarterback you're
crazy why would you not want to use it i
would want it especially if i'm a
younger player you know there's just so
many things that go into running one
play you know in the nfl and to be able
to you know put something on and go okay
they're in this defensive front and you
can kind of go through the mental
checklist when they're in this defense
they run this type of blitz okay let me
you know imitate the mechanics i need to
do you know how you always hear like tom
brady go like mike 50 mike50 you know
those are things quarterbacks had to do
with the line of scrimmage they help you
get just more comfortable with the
process of being a quarterback let alone
not only the closest thing you're gonna
get as far as live reps like you said to
see people moving around and to get a
little feeling of when's the right time
to pull the trigger to throw the
football and you know okay it's time to
move on to the second read and you know
to my eyes go there all those things i
think it's an unbelievable tool and just
the the continuing growing of
quarterbacks and technology and football
is just what's making the sport awesome
aaron said the buccaneers have been
working to put winston in really
difficult situations good idea because
he tends to crumble all too often when
he gets into those difficult situations
but with the virtual reality software
striver is what the buccaneers use you
put the goggles on you can watch our
practice area instead you can turn
around and see the coaches behind you
it's the entire blitz drill so you can
sit in your living room and practice all
day without sweating and it's us
practicing it's not a video game it's
actual practice carson palmer had it in
his house and that was thursday night
for him every week all the blitz pickups
you can see both wide receivers you can
see everything yeah it makes sense it
makes sense and if it makes you better
if it makes you if it helps you wire
your brain so that you can make a better
decision in that one moment that could
be the difference between win or a loss
i mean break it down yeah could be
difference between completion and
completion which could be difference
between touchdown or no touchdown which
is different between win or lose and
that one win could be different between
playoffs or no playoffs which is
different between super bowl or no super
bowl you're right it's all from that
extra word trickle down effect you know
we we always hear the phrase uh right
mike you know oh the game has slowed
down for him you know the game slows
down for people when they're comfortable
and they've gotten a lot of reps and
they go okay this is just another day at
the office well here's a tool that can
do that you know you think about that
thursday night okay whoa here's all the
other teams blitzes you know we ran in
practice you get one more chance to
digest it and be mentally comfortable to
where yeah when you get on the game on
sunday afternoon all of a sudden you go
oh here comes you know the will
linebacker and the free safety they're
creeping down i've seen this before i've
gone through the mental gymnastics and
now you're free to be good at everything
else like you said now oh my mind's
clear i'm not thinking about what i
might need to do because i've already
done it and my mind's clear so now i can
make a good decision and now throw the
accurate football which you're saying
then goes into the trickle-down effect
of the success of your game your team
that drive whatever it may be a
phenomenal tool i would really like to
try it out at some point i think you and
me should both do that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports